sous un chapiteau en forme de cage
jonathan marchand campent devant
l'assemblée nationale soit occupé cette
estampe le tac j'avais pour une
rencontre personnelle avec le premier
ministre monsieur legault j'en attends
marchand souffre de dystrophie
musculaire et il a besoin d'un
respirateur artificiel 24 heures sur 24
à 43 ans il doit vivre dans un ch et
celle des dont il se sent prisonnier il
veut en sortir
et depuis deux ans il propose une
solution clé en main au gouvernement
l'assistance personnelle auto dirigé 11
pour nous les ressources financières
directement la personne souffre on leur
budget personnel et c'est elle qui
autorise à se faire de ce temps elle
choisit restant à des sicav 900 dans
l'ohio à quel endroit et comment donc à
leur contrôle complet sur les services
elle peut adapter les services
pour son mode de vie mais ce marché
on pourrait s'imaginer pouvoir de
passage dans la région pour une annonce
la ministre marguerite blais est allé à
la rencontre de jonathan marchand une
rencontre qui a donné lieu à un vif
échange de plusieurs minutes
on va arriver aussi avec un plan n'était
à domicile ça sent viella est-ce que ça
inclut le soutien de ses gardes et les
personnes qui ont des besoins 24 arsenal
tient on à mantoue solution clé en main
c'est plus un parti pour ce qui est d'un
train une volonté politique
1900 les changements je veux profiter de
la première manche je lis volonté
politique là le propre projet tel que
proposé par mais ces marchands ça
implique donc mais l'histoire est
ça correspond pas non plus à l'ordre des
professions quand on en vient à poser
des gestes d'éclat comme celui là c'est
qu'on a essayé autre chose avant c'est
qu'on a écrit c'est qu'on a parlé c'est
qu'on a fait des coups de téléphone et
un moment donné quand il n'y a pas de
réponse
insatisfaits des réponses de la ministre
blais jonathan marchand n'a pas
l'intention de plier bagage
à ses côtés des amis et d'autres
personnes handicapées kim il est avec
lui on devrait plus avoir d'institutions
il faut arrêter d'investir dans le dans
le médical et dans des bâtisses jeu
maladie évolutive aura éventuellement je
vais avoir besoin de plus ce service
chaque journée passée en sachet se
décante 30 40 et 50 ans une journée
voire trouve qu' on est des gens
prisonniers une note jonathan marchand
dit avoir interpellé le gouvernement de
françois legault à plusieurs reprises
mais sans succès cette fois ci il est
prêt à tout pour obtenir une rencontre
avec le premier ministre même s'il doit
camper plusieurs jours devant
l'assemblée nationale
ici marie pierre bouchard radio canada
québec